one small step for man
giant leap
for finch weinberg
hello
we have caleb landry jones as jeff he
had to wear these huge stilts all this
other cgi friendly stuff
we use mocap a moving suit which is a
suit that records all of your movements
there's a handoff between the legacy
puppeteers who are starting the
evolution of the artificial intelligence
and then visual effects takes over by
having a bunch of animators and caleb as
an actor evolving the artificial
intelligence so legacy they've built a
robot that's the most complex robot
they've ever built there was enormous
amount of parts that were created for
these puppets
jeff was really very different from
other robots that we've done in the past
let's bring him and ground him in the
real world so his head is the top of a
welding gas tank a lot of his body parts
it's all chips there's a lot of
different textures it was very important
that we actually had a physical robot on
set
[Music]
once jeff becomes a fully formed robot
caleb then takes over
it was good to make sure that before you
had jeff become a fully cg character
that you introduce a character to the
audience that is grounded in reality and
in the real world
when i saw it recently i didn't remember
caleb in costume i was just seeing jeff
as jeff a testament i think to to how
fluid caleb was inside all of that
you can't really get the nuances of what
happens on set if it was just a cg thing
that worked perfectly every single time
there's this amazing creature that's not
part of our normal life but that's just
kind of this horror to tell a very very
human story
you